Cara Delevingne, Miley Cyrus, and even Johnny
Depp’s Daughter Lily-Rose recently revealed
they are something other than straight.
Hmm all ladies, just a coincidence or are
women more likely to be bisexual?
Human sexuality is stranger than what our
culture tells us.
Alfred Kinsey was one of the early pioneers
to realize this.
His famous 1-5 scale is still widely used
nearly 70 years later.
Kinsey identified as bisexual and believed
most people fall somewhere in the middle too.
While 2015 has been a huge year for advances
in LGBT rights, bisexuality still remains
an enigma to much of America.
Some consider it a phase on the way to admitting
homosexuality or just a way to get attention
or have fun in college for women.
And those misunderstandings and stereotypes
might do some real damage to bisexuals.
Only 28% of bisexuals are out, compared to
over 70% of gays and lesbians, according to
a 2013 Pew Research Center survey.
So low visibility might be a reason why myths
about bisexuality are so hard to dispel.
But let me reassure you, the latest research
says female bisexuality is very real.
Many studies show that women are more likely
to say they’re bisexual than men.
A recent study from the American Sociological
Association found that to be true.
Researchers followed 5,018 women and 4,191
men from adolescence to young adulthood.
The study asked participants whether they
had same sex attractions or sexual experiences
in the past year.
And women did have a higher probability of
being attracted to both men and women.
Earlier studies seem to find that women in
general are just more likely to be attracted
to both sexes.
One early study, when I say early I mean 2003,
found that women both heterosexual and homosexual
were aroused by both male and female erotica.
And a 2008 study published in the journal
Developmental Psychology also demonstrated
self disclosed fluidity in non-heterosexual
women.
But perhaps more importantly, this study also
found that fluid sexuality isn’t just a
phase.
The survey of 79 queer women found that bisexual
women maintained their attraction to both
men and women over the course of ten years.
But still bisexual women and women who didn’t
label themselves were more likely than lesbians
to change their label.
But mostly it was a change between bisexual,
and unlabeled than it was to lesbian or heterosexual.
Only 8% of women changed their identity to
lesbian or heterosexual.
So think of the Kinsey scale.
Sexuality is a spectrum, where most people
fall in the middle; certainly a lot of women
do.
But unfortunately, social biases codify attraction.
The ASA study also found that social context
matters a lot when it comes to female sexuality.
Women who were rated as more attractive by
their interviewers (there’s a big old asterisk
here), had higher levels of education and
avoid young motherhood, were more more likely
to rate themselves as “100% heterosexual”.
The researchers think maybe romantic options
could influence a woman’s sexual identity.
Even if she feels attraction to more than
one gender, a more attractive woman would
have better heterosexual options simply might
make her less likely to explore her homosexual
options.
And on the other side of that coin, maybe
that women who have had same sex experiences
are more likely to incorporate that attraction
into their identities.
But the question a lot of people ask, is why
did homosexuality, or in this case bisexuality
evolve?
One of the most prominent theories is that
like bonobos, we bone to bond.
Because sex feels good and is very intimate,
it could help create and strengthen social
bonds.
As for female same sex bonds, one study published
in the journal Evolutionary Psychology, puts
forward the idea that bisexuality helps women
raise their young.
For example if a father dies a woman could
form an intimate partnership with another
woman.
That extra set of hands could help ensure
that child reaches adulthood.
Maybe we’ll never know the “reason”
for bisexuality.
But really at the end of the day, bisexuality
is real.
Science says so.
People say so.
People are aroused by and attracted to lots
of different things.
And that’s okay.
And that’s beautiful.
For a more in-depth look at female sexuality,
check out this video I did with Dr. Kiki Sanford:
We’ve got a link in the description below
if you’re on mobile.